i appreciate you talking to me about
this this show is quite the wild ride
yes
i'm curious when the opportunity to be a
part of this project came your way and
you hear that it's a tv version of i
know what you did last summer what was
your reaction did you immediately have
questions had you been familiar with
movies
i was a big fan of the original movie
from the 90s
and yeah of course i had lots of
questions um i remember reading the
pilot for the first time and kind of
went in with the blanks blank slate like
you know not really expecting anything
or not knowing what to expect i guess
more so
and and i just loved how they took so
much of the charm from the original but
also created something completely new on
top of that um
also you know our story does start the
same way it's a fatal car crash a
cover-up
and a killer who will literally stop at
nothing to horrify us all
um but at the same time it's a fresh
take and our story is very character
driven i loved how
layered and complex all the characters
were and
and and really you know it's more than
just a bunch of teens running away from
a killer it's everyone has a secret
everyone's guilty and no one's really
innocent and so that kind of gets
uncovered you know through every single
episode
how personally just sort of
challenging and upsetting is it to have
like that nameless faceless
boogeyman at least until you know more
about what's going on is it kind of
terrifying to not know like you know the
the figure in the dark
yeah it's it's interesting you know that
was one of the things from the beginning
though the entire cast we were trying to
figure out because i think we got the
first four episodes from the beginning
so we didn't know what the rest of the
show looked like so
we're all you know trying to make
decisions that impact our characters
throughout the rest of the show and and
kind of blindly doing so but we had bets
on set trying to figure out like how
this thing was gonna end and i will say
that every single one of us was wrong
except for one person
um but i was completely wrong i had no
idea i was way off i thought i'd had it
too
how do you personally feel about this
whole idea of reboots and remakes and
reimaginings is it something that you
find yourself interested do you normally
shy away from watching them does it sort
of depend on what the property is
you know it's it's like mixed feelings
because
it's it's so awesome to be a part of
something that people love so much in
the beginning and i think it also pays
tribute to the fact of like
letting them live on for different
generations and in in this way where you
can
reinvent it in some way um i find myself
doing quite a bit of reboots or sequels
like that was awesome but somehow like
jumanji goosebumps
you know
i know what you did last summer i'm
still here um but for me though
i i fall in love with things that
already came out so
to be a part of something that is
already so iconic
it's a lot of pressure but at the same
time it's it's really exciting because i
had such an impact on me personally
yeah and it must be fraying because the
way this this is approaching it you know
just taking the idea and then sort of
deviating from there you're not playing
the same characters so you don't have to
feel like you have that to live up to
yes yeah yeah because that that's a
whole nother thing when you know you're
fully recreating something um
and that can be a whole lot scarier at
least as you know we're like making a
whole new world within their
circumstances
what was your reaction to the idea of
playing twins what most excited you
about that what made you most nervous
about that
so much um
i feel like it's every actor's you know
it's always on their bucket list
rarely do you ever get the opportunity
yeah it depends if you ever do um
so i was definitely up for the challenge
and uh i think the scariest thing for me
was
when you first meet these twins it's
right in the middle of this grad night
so
there's a lot of pressure on like making
and selling them as twins and kind of
like building this backstory
of everything that happened before that
you know their mother committed suicide
when when they were little girls and and
sort of just how alison has always felt
in the shadow of her sister and like
really doing the background on that to
make sure all of that came through uh on
screen
um also the technical side of twins was
very interesting
uh i i knew it was gonna be a challenge
but it's definitely time consuming you
know because you're doing double of
everything and i think all of my
heaviest dialogue scenes were all with
my twin
so it was definitely it was a lot of
work
obviously anything spoilery i will keep
till after it's a spoiler
what's it like to not only develop two
separate characters and figure out who
they are and why they are the way they
are but to then explore them in
flashbacks to
explore them at different times in their
lives and then to figure out
you know when
one is living as the other how you layer
that onto it i mean it just seems like
so
so many complications it is it's it's a
lot and it's it is a show about people
wearing
many different hats you know and it is
it's it's not just allison it is many
different characters and
everyone has a secret and and they all
slowly become revealed throughout the
entire series but
i mean it's definitely there's so much
happening
at the same moment that
it is sometimes hard to keep your head
on people like where you are in a
specific scene but i mean that's we have
an amazing showrunner sarah goodman who
definitely helped us keep on track and
and just worked with so many so many
great people but you know storytelling
sometimes is easy and sometimes comes
with the challenge but
i always enjoy a challenge i think it's
fun
you have a pretty large ensemble of
actors that you get to work with in this
what's it like to have this big group to
work with but to then also know that
you're going to lose some of them when
they're gruesomely murdered you know i
think we all knew what we were signing
up for this uh it's still you know the
reality is still something else yeah
yeah and it's but it's exciting at the
same time and they're all so great and
so talented um we had so much fun every
single day
i'm a huge horror movie fan so like this
was so fun for me um but yeah no we
definitely knew we were signing up for i
think when we all first met we because
we all got the first four episodes and
we were like all right
we don't know what's happening after
this like we gotta buckle up and just
get ready for anything
is it ever just do you ever laugh when
you're filming a scene that's just
horribly gruesome i mean it seems like
it's kind of when you think about how
you know it's all make-believe it must
get a little silly too yeah absolutely
it does and also you know we're doing
night shoots and we are all losing our
minds at three in the morning so yeah
when
someone is dying won't say who at three
in the morning and everyone sleep
exhausted it definitely can get a little
silly but you know our editors are
amazing and they make it look scary and
sometimes we're actually like we were
deathly afraid we worked in a couple
locations that i'm pretty sure we're
haunted
um so those are pretty spooky
and but then even you know the scene of
our car crash like that was a pretty
emotional several nights we we filmed
that um
and yeah like that was totally different
you know it was it was nice to kind of
have each other there to kind of help
support and lean on each other because
those were two very long nights
this is a show that also has a lot of
adult content and lennon in particular
seems to be right at the center of most
of the things that happen in that sense
whether it's
drugs or using sex or however she can
manipulate somebody
what's it been like to take on that kind
of material are there always
conversations about what it will look
like and why she's doing what she's
doing
i mean there's there's conversations
from the very beginning even just from
the words on the paper you know and like
what exactly we want what we want it to
look like
how
what we want people to feel from it you
know um
i mean it's it's interesting because
every character in in the decisions they
make you know there are consequences
that come even throughout you know
towards the end of of the entire series
so
especially someone like lennon who does
purposely manipulate people through
these things
i mean it was it was a little scary for
me because she is a bold character and
i'm kind of the complete opposite so i
had to tap into something inside of me
you know to kind of go there but uh
you know it was something as far as like
the intimate scenes and it's always
something i've wanted to do and
especially in
in that way like it was fun you know i
tried to find the fun in it um because
at the end of the day it's an
entertaining show
and and i felt so comfortable and safe
and everyone was just so great
and there was definitely
at least so far from what i've seen
always a story reason
yes always i mean everything we do
is for a reason every decision someone
makes is always revealed later on why
they did that or you know the
each episode you kind of get a glimpse
into each character's perspective of
that night so when you see something in
the first episode that moment might come
back five episodes later and it will all
make sense you're like oh okay that's
what happened and why that person did
that so our whole show was kind of like
a giant puzzle and then finally by the
end you'll have all the pieces
the father-daughter relationship plays a
big role in this story too and it's such
an interesting dynamic because clearly
their relationship was strained there
was a lot of tension there and now she's
in this weird
position and he knows at least more than
most other people what's going on so how
important is that relationship
especially you know taking all that into
consideration what was that like to
explore because i don't think we've seen
too many father-daughter relationships
like that oh um and bill heck he's
the greatest i love that man he's he was
my rock you know the kind of this whole
time filming we had a lot of heavy
scenes together
and he takes a lot of that load you know
he's his character goes through it um
you know but but it's interesting and
without spoiling too much you know the
thing that happens and um
so they're kind of forced to have each
other and they they both lost something
that was so important to them
and then alison is kind of forced to
face
this relationship with her father that i
think she was
you know it's she avoided for so long
and and
and then there's other this show is so
hard to talk about and there are
things that come up um but you know they
have a very interesting relationship and
i think her dad really does love her but
i don't know if allison will ever
believe it i don't think she'll believe
anyone ever fully loves her because she
doesn't love herself yeah
yeah that's why it's so interesting
because there's so many emotional levels
going on with all of these people
lots of emotions
lots of love triangles lots of
lots of emotions
you talked about guessing and guessing
wrong
what was your reaction when you actually
found out the answers once you knew what
was happening
what was your first response
i think i was in shock
but then
after i took a second to process like it
all made sense
um so i
the show is giving you all the pieces to
put it together yourself it's also
giving you lots of pieces and misleads
and
you will get lost because there's
literally no way you could unless you're
just really good and i'll be very
impressed if some people are able to put
this together with the first four
episodes but um it's not like we hide it
from you it's there it's there the whole
time it's just a matter of if you can
put it together or not
you said there was one of you that
guessed right was that did they have
like a logical reason for guessing the
way they guessed or was it just like a
random guess and they just got lucky i
would tell you who it was but i think
that would give it away they are very
smart
so there was like a logic for their
conclusion yeah yeah of course i mean
the ending makes sense it does but then
also you know there's and you will find
out the more episodes you go through is
there are many many secrets that are
revealed throughout every single one so
it's not just the big finale of the end
like everyone everyone is guilty of
something
yeah no i'm just curious because i've
watched horror movies with friends while
they're they'll guess somebody and it's
just they randomly guess and then they
just accidentally write so that's why i
was curious
this person very much put it together
well since since this is a show that
loses cast members and characters are
killed off have there been conversations
about how the show could continue in
other seasons like do you know what the
next steps in the story would be
well you'd have to see if i made it um
if multiple meme makes it
um
but i mean
of course everyone wants to show to do
really well and sarah is a mastermind so
i'm sure she has something in the works
of what she would like to do for a
second season but who knows who will be
live
it's funny because i watched them like
are we gonna then be following like some
neighbor kid we didn't know existed
because they'll be the only one left
standing at the end
you know who knows i will say our show
goes
it gets pretty great have you seen any
of have you seen one through four yeah
okay so after four or two it gets it
gets pretty it gets pretty nuts yeah no
that's why i said it's it's a wild ride
watching the show i mean every time i
thought i knew what was happening and
then it threw another curveball and i i
tend to be somewhat good with guessing
where things are going and this this
show definitely kept me on my toes you
have any idea
not at the moment i don't because every
time i think i have an idea like that
person ends up dead or something happens
that usually happens in our show yeah
well i enjoy that very much it's so much
fun because it feels like it's it's so
easy to see things coming and i just i
love it when you can't so
i appreciate definitely appreciate you
talking to me about it and i can't wait
to see more of it yeah of course i'm
excited for you to see more we'll see if
your final guess is the right one i'm
sure it won't be but i'll i'll keep a
notebook so that i can prove it to
somebody if it is
awesome thank you so much
it's good to talk to you
you